let's talk about Obamacare the
Affordable Care Act the last few days
have seen a number of very very apoplexy
an out-of-control headline saying
shocking Obama care premiums up twenty
two percent twenty five percent in some
cases and yes it is true that under the
Obamacare Affordable Care Act law
premiums for those plans will be up an
average of twenty two percent next year
there are many consumers who will be
down to basically just one plan option
through the Obamacare exchanges and this
is not just opposition reporting the
administration itself has indeed confirm
this but the misinformation from so much
of the alarmist out-of-control reporting
on this it's so extensive that I want to
dig into it with you here at the top of
the show there are a whole bunch of
different pieces of information that are
missing from these reports people see a
report saying Obama care premiums up 22%
number one that ignores the subsidies on
those plans so while you will have an
average and this is based on the Silver
level plans now there's Bronze Silver
Gold and Platinum level plans that sort
of established generally how much of
one's health insurance expenditures are
covered by insurance silver is the sort
of benchmark that is used twenty-two
percent increase in Obamacare Silver
level plans however most of that
increase for many Obama care recipients
is going to be covered by subsidies so
you see the headline and it makes for a
really great headline but it's not
actually telling us well how much more
are the individuals actually going to be
paying and of course this ignores all
together that this has nothing to do at
all with individuals who have insurance
through their parent's insurance through
their employer insurance through their
school etc so really really interesting
headline Republicans are going
absolutely nuts about this we've heard
the term death spiral be used many many
times that Obamacare is just going to
basically self-destruct and implode but
is super super important to understand
that this refers to a small percentage
of all the people in the country and it
also is not accounting for the fact that
many of these increases are going to be
covered additionally let's not forget
that we've been seeing increases to
premiums for a very very long time and
even without the Affordable Care Act we
would be seeing increases to premiums
would they be higher or lower than with
the Affordable Care Act well it's hard
to say remember that even without the
Affordable Care Act even without an
insurance mandate uninsured people are
still going to go to the emergency room
use it as primary care and those who
have insurance are going to subsidize
that that is a cost part of which is
eliminated by mandating insurance the
way we see through the Affordable Care
Act so there's a whole bunch of stuff
here guys which is not in the headlines
and it completely up ends what the story
here really is yeah we don't really have
a control here to see how higher the
premiums would have gone out up without
Obamacare no damn 1999 to 2009 according
to the Kaiser Institute premiums for
families nearly doubled and the
republican response to all this is just
to blow the whole thing up to repeal it
and kick 20 million people off their
coverage no doubt yeah and insurance
subsidies cap premiums at a percentage
of families income so many Americans
will end up paying more and another
issue here is that this number also
hides a lot of local variation that
people are unaware of this is not a
perfect system right I don't think Pat
thinks obamacare is perfect uh I don't
think Rachel thinks obamacare is perfect
I've been clear that Obamacare is not
perfect right it does some good things
the banning of of uh outrageous price
increases or rejection of coverage for
pre-existing conditions is a really good
thing allowing people under age 26 to
stay on their parent's insurance until
age 26 is a really good thing reducing
or I guess it's really the opposite
growing the pool of people who have
insurance that are paying something in
is a good thing and of course covering
millions of additional people is a
really good thing
but the system at its core is so corrupt
and so immoral and so unethical that is
really the basic issue for me and the
Republicans who complain about the
twenty two percent increase to Silver
level Obama care plans not accounting
for premiums in the fact that most
people aren't even on these plans at all
ignores that the entire for-profit
system we have is the problem and if you
turned it over to Republicans they're
not going to fix that they're going to
say we need more competition we need to
allow insurers to say oh you have a
pre-existing condition you're out
etcetera their views would only make
this problem worse and we know what the
most popular and cost effective health
care programs are around the world yet
single-payer that's what works well in
Britain in all over Europe all over the
world and instead we in America have a
long tradition of getting health care
coverage through our employers yet but
really it's not the best way to go and
Rachel think about uh all of the ways in
which the costs are obviously going to
be high you have middlemen earning
profits in ours in our health care
system all over the place you have
bureaucracy and complexity you have the
entire medical billing apparatus in many
cases preventive medicine is ignored
which we know over the long term
increases costs you're paying for the
uninsured anyway anyway we have this
current situation of the aging baby
boomer population combined with an
obesity crisis that we can't possibly
separate from the factory food epidemic
and sedentary lifestyles of course it's
going to be expensive yeah it's really
difficult also for the families who make
too much to qualify for subsidies
subsidies they will find themselves in a
pinch and I'm equally worried for people
with chronic illnesses that have to
switch plans that may have been getting
on a good price for a drug that they're
receiving for treatment and then when
they switch that costs can go up and
it's super easy to hear what rachel is
saying and say well it's obama's fault
these are systemic issues that are
inherent to the type of of arrangement
we have in this country with regard to
health insurance i've been saying it all
week Hillary Clinton being the next
president will not solve this in any way
I want to be super clear about that but
it will at least allow us a 9th 10th
11th and 12th year of
Democratic presidents to try to take the
Affordable Care Act and expanded and
move it further to the left do yet it do
people also completely just disregard
the fact that since Obamacare was
enacted a lot more people have health
insurance before that jail that's
ignored you know nobody talked about as
we might as well ignore to his hey you
know if you either get it or you're
going to ignore it right i mean it
doesn't even know make it it it really
is bewildering